yeah Loretta's coming in and he's saying
it's mad long to fire rise up about six
shots to my nine cars long time I don't
ride the bus I've got I don't know
what's wrong with the bus I personally I
should have the buses I can't really see
clearly what it looks like a pyramid it
was like a pyramid yes carry on move
there we go dad looks like an eye on the
pavement I'm gonna assume the best see
if I can find the chain okay
[Music]
lady so high-level feed
what then
before the video starts guys check out
sponsors and natures blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sun now the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10% of
their products
dear friends before I water plays a lot
so panel what are the most most of the
moisture or praise glory and gratitude
belong to him guys so a basic about sent
this video through Instagram I don't
know search for this stuff really busy I
really have time bar for this important
- to be shared so yeah if you guys can
watch it with an open mind each other
I'm not here to condemn anyone do me
anyone to hell it's not my job I'm nada
so which one watch and understand what
lessons can we learn from this inshallah
so this is a video from Harry Street
anything she'd artists you should do
nationalities I think used to do music
as well cetera but now he's done a rap
video which he's doing it with a rapper
I want to give the main Niva I advise
you guys to watch it please like or
listen to it you can watch there's
nothing on there's no girls in there
blah
we're gonna play some interesting stuff
because they saw me that caught my
attention the chain that he's wearing as
well when let's watch it first so these
are the lyrics on the less I'm gonna
make that problem bigger from the screen
for you guys the video so let's watch it
sure let's start yeah so I'm gonna put
it on okay play box be this point one
point two five okay here we go
okay so I'm gonna read the lyrics so
this one has days in and they're
dangerous so dangerous dangerous so
dangerous we're from the south
up above us that do work in different
ways if you try and touch that if you
try and touch them fam then you know you
can get erased they asked me how I'm how
I'm making all this money every day if I
step up if I step up in the dark you
know this route is getting ripped well
from the South I've got some bombers
that will put you in your place if you
think I'm playing with you you're making
a mistake
we are down if you spoil you to your
money to be made if you see us in your
city but the novel getting paid we get
some money
so then this the rapper comes in and
it's mad long before I rise up about six
shot to my mind cause long time I don't
ride the bus ago
I personally I actually love the buses
I've got four men and they write cars
okay okay how so hard in daytime do the
same thing when the night comes
okay he's working night shifts duct tape
duct tape one hour for ten but still old
with night gloves don't know that means
no discussion raised if he isn't getting
stabbed or shot he's getting rushed and
taste then my brothers from Jamaica put
it but it will let the Russian brace Sun
Sun spray rising up and who lay let it
seem like Harris Jake how she comes in
with the same bastard ah so then it goes
back soon I think there's a couple of
people rapping I don't know this another
guy okay so it's not that today
today India we're just talkin it's hard
sure if I post you but connects bond
like the bullring might pull up on you
with this booting I can practice on the
back strip in the black whip with two
white clips know what that means
you call beef and practice you called me
from practice I just want you to come to
clap for me hide even dangerous for me
hides
I've been dangerous with this hunting
I've been dangerous when the four pounds
my favorite say you shoot and you are
dangerous but I don't believe like I'm
an atheist don't believe don't believe
now I'm gonna come up and squeeze in
favorites tell your mom and brother
better pray for him or everybody's gonna
pay for him okay we are down there okay
so oh well finish on time just as ya
know now looking at this guy's house Jay
started with in the sheets I think it
was involved in music he believed in
music but you see how that has kind of
led how that kind of led to music yeah
so what would I do now I'm gonna find
something cuz I noticed something so
okay let's go back here let's go back
he's got a chain on we can't really see
clearly what it looks like a pyramid it
was like a pyramid let's carry on there
we go that looks like an eye on the
pavement I'm gonna sue the best witness
you're the best let's get let's get
closer
that's day there must be a hold on okay
okay cuz this is very very it's kind of
important okay we'll close up little
close up let's see if we can find the
chain okay that's an eye that's a night
I don't know if you guys can see I'm
gonna try to make a big on the screen
that is an eye that's a night
no look guys this is this this I don't
know what's going on here
sometimes people connect the eye to all
kind stuff in the minority etc sometimes
it's conspiracy theories there might be
some truth into it dodge a one-eyed
music video rap video one eye I don't
know what's going on now there's a
principal in the machine that we have
something that can lead to her on can
become her arm itself now I want to give
an advice to you guys how do I start off
with machines firstly I want to say look
on my head to judge him we judge for
what's apparent but I'm not here to
judge him let me differentiate we just
want to plan what he's doing this room
and we're going to talk about that room
but we're not gonna call me and say he's
doomed to hell he's finished I'm better
than him I'm righteous I'm Muslim and
this I'm that he's finished his dad his
dad is a fast set his days were etc I'm
not gonna go down that route it's clear
we can see what he's doing
we're gonna talk about the outer action
yeah and we're going to talk by the
table told that's that before we see
judge from what was revealed now the
revelation is top judge for was apparent
so there's no to party oh yeah when you
got control me we don't miss Islam so
now we can clearly see that this is a
this is a simple drug it's it's some
kind of a knife
we don't know why it's there we don't
know why it's there but the thing is
Harry straight starting from YouTube
videos we're gonna share videos from
there led to music now we need a mood
when you open the doors to music that's
going to lead to a lot of other stuff
cuz once you believe music is
permissible you're just gonna tell you
where it stops
you're gonna Clarion whatever kind of
music is now music has a massive impact
on your brain before contestant elevated
drops I made an alcohol and I was none
of those music was a fitness for me and
when I stood music I would get high yeah
in my jaw he was involved in gangs and
stuff like that we listen to us
music we are ready to kill a very
straight with you we are ready to go out
and kill because that's how much it
affects your brain some people say that
the certain part of your brain which is
for logic and reason
music overtakes that it overtakes that
so it's not dopamine it's not drugs you
see now alas paralyzed critics with the
Fitzer emanate this position then we a
program or something and if we don't
protect the Pfitzer and keep it secure
what happens is when we open it to doors
like today people are open to everything
whatever you want you can be yeah some
people they want to be a piano they want
to be a TV somebody wants to be a light
bulb shine shine bright like a light
bulb go shine into the world you know
you're like Bach no problem we cater for
you yes you're a light bulb yes shine go
go go to the dark streets of Aleppo yeah
bring some light in turn you can be
whatever you like there is no limit
whatever you want to be do it male
female gender neutral no problem
baboon hippo dinosaur whatever you want
what they're doing is they are seen
there is no limits whatever you desire
is one go for it and this is why it's so
fundamental if we look at Shaitaan
Shaitaan decides I'm better than Adam he
said I'm better than Adam why because
he's saying he knew Allah oh Allah I
mean he knew Allah I was tending to bow
down he said no I am better than him now
did he fall into ship and this belief
because he disobeyed Allah no because I
did the same as well what a second Adam
did the same animal a sir I'm eatin for
that I don't pay from the tree when I
last one children want to do it how do I
say how come she thought because it's
not the sin we don't believe the major
Center or the - seen that take cell
phone miss ma'am he ascribed my mistakes
all I said all I'm better than him so he
sent over you our room my desire say I'm
never gonna bow down to Adam so what is
doing is that your desires overtake you
and what does Allah send her on have we
seen the one who takes his desires as
his Lord so we think when we worship a
someone it's not only we bow down to
them one of the Companions of the first
470 was a Jewish before I think and he
said to him first I said son son said to
me you used to take your rabbis as your
Lord he said we never worshipped our
rabbis he said did you not take it when
they made something Haram Helen say
something
haram they said no this allowed some of
those holidays in the salon he said yes
we did it cuz that's how you used to
worship them and this was something to
do today
so now you see when we don't control the
fit I start watching pornography so
what's the principle anything but least
the Haram can become her arm itself yeah
so that's the reason why Allah says no I
wanna talk abou sinner don't come close
to zina why because it were I run this
is a don't commit sin I said don't come
close to it man anything that can lead
to it move away move or anything
TechSmith move away why because the
thing is when you open those doors yeah
we're just gonna link you just were just
getting to know each other I'm gonna
meet each other you know where the tool
what happens is that doors are opened
now it's just that okay we'll just me
sex let me drop you home you drop a home
ah it's dark you know uh you know yeah
it's a bit cold outside
okay no problem and Shaitaan is the
master should time to talk to you in six
seven ways he tries to get to commit
[ __ ] worship other than Allah you can't
do that
he gets you to commit bitter innovation
within the religion he can't get to do
that he's gonna make you commit a major
sin shaytan's got the whole plan pyramid
in place yeah he can't make you commit
major sins he's gonna go for your -
since cuz when he makes commit those
minuses and analysis carry on carry on
carry on he ain't gonna turn in the
major sins
you know if you don't repent if you
can't commit makes you come in - since
it gonna make you do the lesser of the
two cuts or make you busy with things
that are permissible yeah you're so
you're doing things which you can do
more you better but you're just carrying
on doing these things that's how it's
not a taxi so that's what when you open
these doors one thing leads to another
so what brother Harry state I was so
panicked Allah bless him guide him and
guide myself and all of you guys only
examine the sheets from the sheets
Museum no no this is a territory where
is blurred I innocent in a sheet I'm
doing that she's helped me stop missing
to music when I first came to esta I'm
doing nice to listen to some of them
today but you see when you open the
Berenstain music and you think that
having music and some stomach words it's
gonna look it's halal what happens you
don't stop it start to nog Rafi you
watch pornography two people having sex
and then that's not enough then you go
to your something gonna start watching
gay sex case it's not animal sex and all
sex you know not having intercourse with
a piano and all kind of stuff yeah
why because you open in a flip it
it wants more injection it wants that
bus the bus is not the anymore your
board I want a higher bus and it goes
and carries on and on and on and on do
you reach a point subhanAllah so this
might be the case we bought a Harris
train but I have see if you're watching
this well I don't see me I was like you
can call me her on police I'm there I'm
just look I'm not here to condemn anyone
I'm just giving advice to your fans your
follows please cuz you guys on this
journey you need to understand he's
going through his own journey if you go
there with him you might get addicted
sure and start music whatever maybe he
might repent he might be better than all
of us put together and he might be in
search of Allah you're gonna be caught
up I can I'm up do some wrong stuff
gambling citizen etc I'm a repent now if
you guys have caught up you're going now
I'm like yo fam I free myself and when
the danger is me is gonna be like if you
repent and if it changes weights etc and
sure don't we ask Allah to guide him in
our self you guys are gonna be my shop
so I'm talking to you guys this is your
acid I don't ruin it for anyone now the
reason why it will advise and why this
is so dangerous is because not only the
music put the music side to aside
suicide here this being violence being
promotes it being glorified I'll stop
him shoot him tase him you know how many
people are dying you know how many
families are being destroyed my brother
Harris you're involved in this Banu
Israel in the hood and all I told them
not to fish in the suburb there are
three groups among them what the
scholars say the first one is those who
didn't listen to Allah and when a fish
in the suburb Allah destroyed them there
was another group who said don't do it
we are not going to do what you're doing
Allah save them and this policy there's
a third group this third group was here
they never said go to the supper I mean
go fish disobey Allah maybe they say
don't they were just like yoke we're
just we're just watching the first group
warn them this group Allah said they
will be destroyed also why because they
saw the evil and they want to do nothing
about if you see even you not doing
nothing about it you're part of it now
let alone you're in a music video
promoting glorifying shooting constantly
stuff I done another video which you
guys can watch after this offer Bravo
whose friend got shot dead and we hide
his identity is on the run now okay
story
I spoke to his mom his mom was fearing
for his life we had to get involved help
him get him out the country is about the
country they were looking for me
they are the president that he's gonna
get killed we tried to help him now
you're here Bravo Harris and you're
promoting this people families have been
destroyed Baba
okey well I you believe me you can say
I'm doing this for the fame and the
money could it whatever you like
yeah I'm just genuinely saying if
there's I hope there's a pattern we have
sincerity in me Harris please man and
his followers please please please if
how he's going on his journey okay for
you guys because this can cause
destruction this can end up in
destruction you lost I lost once and it
says guide him in our soul but please
for the sake of Allah people are dying
don't glorify this man talk refer we see
mothers we see people being buried
buried Six Feet Under
their friends don't give a single damn
about them what lie did you not care a
damn about them they being shot stabbed
your friends gonna run for his life what
life is gonna run for his life and your
girlfriend's brother police for the sake
call us at Hanna wa taala stay away from
this man you wanted listen to music
that's your personal thing at least stay
away from this man so guys this is just
a little Nasir for me to you guys you
taking it on taking us up to you I'm
here just to advise why cuz it's an
advice for me I've been in that kind of
lifestyle a bit I know what it entails I
know how destructive and I discussed in
that last honest man and Harris you
don't need to turn to me you won't talk
to me you can sit if you're not gonna
help me brother I'm here for you don't
feel like I'm judging you or not I'm not
saying you ready said I need to talk
about what's apparent and we're in a
chamber over at least you're wearing a
chain but it has this eye symbol I don't
know man you need to be careful man this
is I don't know what's his title but
this you know hieroglyphics all these
kind of ancient stuff Egyptian stuff I
the gel we done a video about this
Antichrist
well my he this is not a joke Rafa why
this is not a joke it's not just the
music now it's promoting violence not
the violence now you've got some stuff
that is like guys that's what I'm gonna
say may Allah bless you guys
so neck
time he watched his piece watch the next
video about the guy who's involved in
gangs Washington Shawa his story and
watch the Antichrist video as well and
yeah man it's it's dangerous stuff man
and may Allah guide us and make the do I
like the process and I'm said all turn
of the hearts keep our heart firm a new
religion so I wanna come